the Soaps are believed to have migrated
in the 6th Century from the Carpathian
Mountains in Central Europe to these
forest and present-day Germany surviving
attempts to germanize their ancient
culture tens of thousands to live in
this region not far from the Polish and
Czech borders
every year at Easter Martina Hoffman
tries to preserve the Serbian tradition
of egg painting like her ancestors she
gives the ex different symbols with
special messages for good health
happiness and prosperity with the
involved sounds
I will use a symbol of the wolf's tooth
to protect against evil spirits it is
used for homes animals and people the
egg is a symbol of fertility they used
to throw an egg on a field in spring so
it would become fertile the egg has
always been important
while the egg decorating tradition lives
on these days much of the symbolism is
forgotten now it has mainly become a
popular art form the Soaps have managed
to preserve their culture for over a
thousand years mainly because they've
lived quite isolated along these
waterways they have survived Wars
communism Nazism but now technology is
threatening their native language
[Music]
with Serbian songs the community tries
to prevent their language from being
lost it is estimated that from around 80
000 sorbs only twenty thousand still
speak Serbian a mix between polish Czech
and other languages
a Serbian TV channel and sobian schools
help to keep the language alive but
competition with German is hard
there is no option to use Serbian on
your computer for win this example and
there are many programs made especially
for sorbent language but the question is
are we actually using this in daily life
and the answer is no he does manage to
convey a message in zorbian though
I wish the whole world a happy Easter
with their songs disorders not only want
to send a message of survival but also
of Peace aslavic people were very
disturbed with the war currently in
Europe it was Unthinkable for us as a
community that this could happen we need
our connections with Slavic people like
we've had for Generations so we hope
this war will end soon the swords hope
to get more government support to keep
their language and culture alive they
say after surviving for more than 1500
years it would be a great loss for it to
disappear stepfather Al Jazeera
spraywald Germany